but guys it's right here dude you've
never heard of a red-haired guy and
people like that guy
has got the [ __ ] like this have you
that means canelo alvarez
yeah he never takes the underwear off at
the weigh-in
let's get back in the sauna real quick
get this last half pound off let me get
this blood going
you know what i mean i gotta make it
loosen this thing up you tell us when
you're ready chin
we're good we're good let's do this man
gary allen what's up the legend
dude you've been uh you've been
podcasting like a maniac next door here
i know right slow down man i know like
well i don't live here so i got to do
like
craigslist three where do you live uh
northern california
up in the bay area you can see him on
the ground the new house like goddamn
gary
flexing well flexing a little bit kobet
jesus back on the road gonna pay for the
house yeah are you back on the road
mm-hmm
how long have you been back on i went
back it's spot
uh june i started to go back and then uh
you know like they'll cancel on like i
remember phoenix i was supposed to be
there they canceled on tuesday my first
show was third stand up live
yeah so they canceled quick on that
that's got rescheduled but
i've been i've been back you know one of
the comics have been
i mean there's a there's a few i i don't
want to say there's a handful of comics
actually a lot of comics who are touring
through the
pandemic yeah yeah there's a lot you can
catch it if you can catch it in the air
it's kind of like you can catch it
anywhere yeah it's like a dr
seuss book yeah
i can't wait to see how this ends dr
seuss i think it catches in the air i
didn't realize that i just i rhymed
do you you remember man uh
when starting out in la you and i
started out in a lot of the same joints
um who's been the game longer i think
maybe gary but it's around the same time
late 90s right yeah and so what room
because when i first started in
la i couldn't get on stage at the store
in the airport so i was doing like rudy
moreno's rooms oh yeah
the the commerce casino oh yeah and and
and
down in el chico i did a room in el
cheek over the dude who tried to pay me
in hookers he was like tell me which one
you want i'm like i
actually just need gas money
[ __ ] oh dude
actually pretty hungry man
what what rooms did you start out in in
la like where did
all the black ones me too did you do
this theater did you do the comedy union
and something like that a little bit
after yep comedy wasn't around um
when i started it was it was the comedy
theater on like friday then there was
mavericks flat
yeah saturday and monday night was
the um laugh fact monday night was
improv sunday night was a laugh factory
and then tuesday was
uh fat tuesdays and those are black
nights black nights
i tried i i did what you're supposed to
do i i did the whole
stand in line for three hours for the
open mic to try to be a paid regular
and i did it like two three times and it
finally got on
and i've told the story before but mitzi
uh
the night i showcased to be a paid
regular there was five of us it was four
girls and me
and i went last and when i went on the
stage and i got five minutes
uh i looked in the back room and mitzi's
holding court with the four girls
like she didn't watch me and then i i
called like the manager hey did i
make it or not now and i went she didn't
even see me she didn't see my [ __ ]
but but brian's talked about that
because when he went i guess that
happened a lot of people
and when brian went on i forget who it
was but they sat next to mitzi and was
like
please watch him and she was like okay
yeah and then watch them
but i guess she did all the time if the
person who went on before you did well
you were [ __ ] because she was going to
talk to them about
being a regular or being a door person
like i like so if the person
bombed in front of you she was good she
was still or like
they passed all four of those girls or
what i don't know i just know i didn't
make it
and i know uh uh when i
called to say that when they said you
didn't get on
i was just like i'll never go up at this
[ __ ] place
that's what i said to myself it was kind
of good for you though like seinfeld
talks about it not getting passed by
mitzi yeah
and he was like you know at the time i
hated her but he was like he gave me the
chip on my shoulder that i needed
and that's what she said she goes you
need somebody like me to tell you you're
not the best thing around here
you know i didn't enjoy it was like cool
yeah yeah listen i
became the most successful community of
all time yeah when she
passed me i thought okay this means i'm
getting
a thousand sets a week and then you know
but she she passed me and said
now it's time for you to work the door
because she passed me
but by passing me and having me with the
door what she was telling me was
you got work to do yeah i want you to
watch these people i want you
in the environment i want you to watch
all of these greats
basically in sports you'd be a red shirt
yeah like you're on the team
but you you're gonna learn you get get
the reps in when you can
if you're yeah if you're a quarterback
you may not be ready to step right in
you may
sit on the bench and watch them play a
little bit yeah learning the offense i
i will tell you though um starting out
in for me
in the black rooms in the hispanic rooms
was the best thing
that ever happened to me because
they were would like those crowds would
laugh at anything
but they're also going to tell you right
up front whether you're funny or not and
there's no skeletons in the room yeah
because in the history of stand-up when
you see people
uh we'll see videos of people getting
mad or they'll walk out or get offended
yeah you've never seen a black person
get up because they're offended not at a
comedy show yeah they might heckle and
get kicked out because they're drunk
but i ain't ever seen a black man or
black woman get up and be like
that joke offended me take effect it's
real never there's no skeleton those
were
without a doubt the all black rooms were
my f because you
literally could say is it funny does it
make sense
are you not being an [ __ ] they're
gonna laugh well even if it's funny
even like uh with the black when fat
tuesdays especially on tuesday night
when
that was a bananas show every tuesday
nobody knew i ran it for two years
oh damn you did nobody knew what years
with uh
2002 to 2004. tell me the type of people
so people who are listening know
the lineups you were getting at fat
tuesday oh you'd get
cat uh before he was cat like he was cat
in the hat
he had the one tooth and but everybody
knew monster you didn't want to see him
on the list you're like i wanna go after
that dude
no because he had a closer where it was
he played this biggie song
because you ever have your car break
down and he the way he could just
act it out you felt like he was on the
highway and his car was broke down he
lifted up you're flicking people off
and black people just get in their car
and they go back to pumping biggie like
the car never broke down yeah the way he
told it was so perfect
that was his closer for like two years
and you're like [ __ ] i don't want to
follow that because the crowd would be
in hysterics
we get cat um eps
uh it's not unusual for eddie to be in
the audience eddie murphy
it was the spot to be in without a doubt
everybody
wouldn't do it by the improv no no
no even knew like i was running the main
room on tuesdays because what i did guy
tori had it
and god was getting busy i'm about to
let it go so you can't let the go guy i
go there's too many comedians that got
their break
in that room and i was like gotta keep
it going i said
let let me and my wife take it over i go
i'm not changing [ __ ]
it was still guy tori's fat tuesday
security was the same
door people was the same i didn't change
nothing it was just it was
we were just paying people the door guys
and we were getting the door
it wasn't a lot of money probably
roasting three four hundred dollars
every tuesday to be down there at that
time fat tuesday was was the big maybe
besides dublin dublin was had a moment
there too where you could not
dublin was a place on sunset basically
where dane
really i got a great story about dublin
dude by the way
dublin
it was dane's night though like when you
should you tuesdays yes when fat
tuesdays kind of went away
dublin's took over and that was dane
spot oh my god but it was
also that place if you did not get that
crowd
in the first minute it was gonna be a
rough set for you really
oh my [ __ ] god they because they were
young
chatty white people yeah and so were uh
you know and there was a lot of attitude
and if you didn't get them up front they
were just turning to each other and
[ __ ] talking what do you got about
dublin so i heard about it so i went up
there
and uh so i went up the first week i did
it i went up right before dane
and i think somebody made a phone call i
don't know if it was bobby lee or
something
and they was like get gary on he vouched
for me
so i went right before dane and i did
good
and then dame went up and that's when
him and go oh this is the guy they're
here to see because this ford name
really popped yeah right
then i came they said hey come you want
to come back next week i go yeah so i'm
coming next week
and literally i'm supposed to go up
right before dane again
and the last thing that dane's got to go
to where he's going to go up here and go
up after him
so i don't know this is dane's room so
in my mind i'm like great
when that [ __ ] said good night
it was like
it was starting to leak uh
i still gotta hear this buddy so when i
say
they're paying no attention to me it was
like they said good night and i think
the bartender rang the bell like it's
time to party
right so i'm up there nobody's paying
attention to me and i'm going
but i i had like this one table it was
like four dudes they're
dying they're like still at the comedy
club and i'm like
and i go well uh i would say thank you
but i don't think anybody heard me
tonight and then one guy goes literally
this guy goes
don't give up dude you're [ __ ] funny
don't give up
i was like what like i'm already a
headliner
but this [ __ ] was don't give up bro
you're good
yeah dude all my jokes was these four
news like i didn't
talk about the bar nobody heard me no
that was just they were there to see him
and and like they were almost
aggressively
anti whoever else was if you got him you
got him but they were
not gonna give you anything i know a lot
of people have their issues with dane
because
there's so much history there i don't
know where you guys sit with dane
but he's always for whatever reason he's
always been great to me i've had to
follow him he's always been
phenomenal to me and then you know i
know him because he was
so big when i was like in college in
high school he's so he's like the kevin
hart of now right
he was so [ __ ] big but what people
don't like there's all this hate on dane
but when you see you know dane has some
skills man and i've seen dane
[ __ ] destroy rooms at the time story
hecklers
hecklers and do 30 minutes on just the
crowd and
wreck the room dude but you forget how
long he's been doing
everybody's another place to hear about
dave not to cut you off but i just did
it
sorry uh he was getting ready to host
snl
geez so i was at caroline's that weekend
now my audience is black
i don't think his manager knew coming in
so they literally called me
hey you mind if dane goes up for fives
he's working on his monologue for snl
thursday and friday and i go yeah i
don't care so he came thursday
and that it was all black so his
monologue for snl wasn't his act as he's
working his monologue
it just wasn't going over he didn't come
back friday
[Applause]
oh let's go to the cellar let's try the
other room yeah
let's go they was looking at him like
this
i did fat tuesday one time and as i'm
walking on stage
and this was early 2000s so i um
i didn't start to look like i was a
grown-up until probably 2010.
so i was clean-shaven and and i walk on
stage
and before i can get to the mic all i
hear from the crowd is
you better be funny bobby brady and i
was like oh okay
here we go this is not gonna be but if
you look if you're you yes that's it
yeah they rise
i remember i did uh they call it
chocolate sundaes
yeah that's sunday yeah so i did uh i
did chocolate sundaes on
i didn't know it was a chocolate sundae
night they offered me a spawn like [ __ ]
yeah so i'm all excited to drive down
there
like a little dark crowd that's cool man
whatever and so i'm up
i'm upstairs in the green room and
there's only one other white dude the
rest are all black comics and
whatever i'm like oh this is cool man
and the other white dude he's australian
and he
just got off his flight from australia
new comet
but knew the booker and he's telling me
and he's like yeah
you know this is my big break and doing
all this and like how long you've been
doing comedies like
about seven years mate in australia i'm
like oh cool man
so they put him on before so went the
two white guys in the rest of the
black uh comics and so he go like
there's an mc who's crushing it
they bring the australian up and he does
he does the most racist set i've ever
seen
he's he's pretending he's a black girl
and he's like y'all you'll know how but
he he does like this weird like american
urban
slang boy oh my it went over
so bad and i'm in the back like [ __ ]
dude [ __ ] so he eats all the dicks
and it was so off-putting everything
they bring me up in the crowd like nah
man it was a
nightmare really that story what was
that story and maybe i'm
maybe i'm gonna uh get this wrong
there's a good chance i am because i
smoked a lot of weed my memory's
terrible but wasn't there
didn't stan hope have a a rough night
at the improv when they were due i think
he tried
he was like i'm gonna work in the n-word
don't do that no
i know i know but but you know how edgy
like i i think it was stan hope and i'm
like i'm i'm i'm sure i'll get corrected
but it was like
when that started or monday nights when
what the
money is so monday nights and i think
you know because doug likes to push the
envelope and i
and i thank you i remember this story i
wasn't there but i remember hearing that
and i think he
put the n-word in a set he was really
man he's always tried to push the
envelope
and make it okay because of who he is
and by the way
i respect the [ __ ] out of doug and his
stand up oh he's one of the great
the some of the things he says i'm like
how do you get away with saying that and
have it still be the funniest thing i've
ever heard it's well written everything
it's that but he i remember that night
and i forgot i didn't know if you were
there that night but i i i
burned the stage down i think he had to
be walking
what i heard about they were just so
shocked yeah they were like what the it
was
it was bubbling yeah it was almost like
what the [ __ ] he just said and
everybody looked around he kept doubling
down oh he doubled down
he said he sat and doubled down i think
he doubled down yeah
i'm sorry don't do that yeah no no
there's no
there's it's like i saw looking at the
book i saw sebastian kill a fat tuesday
one night and just was sebastian that's
all you have to do and that's before
he blew and that's the night i went that
guy's pretty good
yeah yeah you know what i mean he just
went up there was himself
and he did what he kind of did what they
did on um rey
because the room's lit the room went
dark and the spotlight hit him
yeah and it turned into his show and i
go what was [ __ ] he's a smart
man do you do a lot of sets in norcal
still or no you took home with the
family and then you're on the road doing
sets
i'm there this weekend they're doing
outside shows at tommy t's
uh they're gonna they fence off the park
i had to get a video of it first
i don't know what this is about but it
looks cool they fence off the parking
lot
and everybody's gonna have the silent
disco headphones on so
nobody can hear me except the people in
the audience that's kind of dope
i like that i like that better than
drive-ins i like that a lot
it makes it really personal and i dm
some people that win i went to
instagram and followed tommy t's and
went to the location and then i saw
people so i would start dming them first
they'd be like this ain't you
i was like no how was it like
anything yeah and they go everybody said
they loved it because one you're not
getting interrupted
so you can hear everything perfect and i
like that more than the other side
yeah it's a different it makes more
sense to me than the driving
yeah because the drive-in look you're
mixing with all the other ambient noises
so it's harder to really focus in on
the car yeah you're in a car you're
honking the other thing with drive-in
too
just from a business aspect is it's
expensive
so to put it on the show to put on the
the whole squad to do it's expensive
huh but they're ready to go like the x's
and o's are a little dicey they're ready
to go out in california because we
started at four
i'm at 10 shows now and we keep adding
i'm into monday
because the weekend's gone and it's
selling out like
in an hour and how many people are 170
is the cap that's oakland right yeah
it's
pleasant yeah tommy t's but they're just
i go that just tells you california's
ready they're ready to go out
everybody is they're just people yeah
our government's not but the rest of the
people are ready to go i didn't realize
this my my agent called me and i was
like dude
why why i'm on this run of clubs that
keep getting canceled at the last minute
yeah you know what i mean he goes i'm
just gonna keep you in the uh red states
i guess the republic the states were
republican governors correct those
comedy clubs are open correct the
democratic ones
are closed i'm like oh it's all
political now it's all political
yeah and i we just want to make a living
right
like and people just want to go out and
have a good time but let the clubs like
you realize how many people's jobs are
on the line they got to feed their
families too so
there's that it's also like let the
people make their decision if they want
to go out there and enjoy a common show
let them decide i have a question for
you though
and i don't know this because i'm not
smart enough but is the reason that some
businesses
aren't opening or insisting on face
masks or whatever it is
i'm assuming there's got to be some sort
of insurance issue right because if i
get sick
wherever i am and i die how are you
going to prove that
you could have got it anyway but the
trace like like entertainment uh
for like movie sets and stuff like that
that insurance through the roof
but i think with outdoor events and like
the yeah i have no idea
you sign a waiver because when i did um
when i did wise guys in salt lake like
they were so
professional about it and they had to
sign a wave or go like if you do get
something here wherever
like we're not re responsible for it and
most no fans like no that's ridiculous
right yeah you've got no [ __ ] dude the
clubs are being good i mean some are
some i
some i'm like oh dude there's yeah i did
one in atlanta i was like this they
don't give a [ __ ] yeah
i would say what i did when i was like
oh we're definitely all getting cold
and we all do it yeah we all do it
really and i'm sure people can figure it
out
[Laughter]
oh that's funny yeah yeah i mean because
that [ __ ] was past
housing just ain't good man yo yesterday
i'm
i was out getting a coffee right yeah
and i was at
whole foods getting a coffee now because
i was also shopping
and so when i come back this dude is
waiting for his coffee
but he's got his hands on the top of my
lid
oh man so you don't even without
covering even though i touch my [ __ ]
coffee that's what i said to him i go
hey man
what why is your hand why is your hand
on the mouth hole you know what i mean
like what why'd you
say it like that hey man that's what i
do that's just my thing
that's always my thing like it might be
his way to pick up dudes
it's funny as comedians like we'll hear
a joke and not laugh hard but
just a couple words yeah the way
somebody says it i'll just be [ __ ]
dying like right there
hey man because you almost have to
surprise us
do you know what i mean if you're
telling me a joke will we process
everything yeah i'm just thinking about
your job
yeah yeah absolutely everything but this
dude hand on the mouth hole
and i go hey i go hey hey man hey man
yeah touch my mouth i go back i go well
i
i i are you touching i go why are you
touching the mouth hole
why is that you i go that's my coffee
and he goes oh sorry man he goes do you
believe this cove at stuff and i said
the same thing i go
no i go hey man even no cover i don't
want your hand finger in my watercolor
am i wrong on that like no hell no why
are you no you don't have anybody's food
period
never coveted no coverage don't do that
you don't don't lean on life
never and he was like if you're gonna be
if you're gonna be i
forget the word he said was the older
dude he was probably 28.
oh i figured older dude most old people
don't give up
28 a bigger guy tight tank top
just leaning in just leaning on my
coffee so i was trying to go hey man
because he was a large [ __ ]
anyway so i didn't want to get too
aggressive hey man
yeah i'm trying to think what com like
obviously i got covered but as far as
like big name comics deal hugh glue is
probably the other one who got
you know there's nothing well kevin said
he had it kevin hart said he had it
but he was smart about it that's where i
[ __ ] up i was like hey y'all got
covered hey
yeah [ __ ] you he got it in like months
went by isaac yep i had it but i don't
want to tell everybody i mean
joe was almost michael yo was like on a
uh breathalyzer right like he was a
ventilator i mean
yeah yeah i mean he got he was yeah he
was yeah
exhausted yeah i think some other [ __ ]
was going on though he got
let me it was funny my agent called me
and did you guys
he said are comics calling you guilting
you for going back on the road
just some comments low level guilty just
low level like [ __ ] comics
oh cause i told my agent i go uh no i'm
a black comic
um
no no we don't do that in the black
world
the black comics calling me like hey how
was it yeah it's your money [ __ ]
i can't imagine corey holcomb calling
you by the way to me corey might be the
most underrated comic
it he makes me laugh do you know corey
holcomb at all
i don't think so you're correcting him
like he laughed so
guys this is so inappropriate but yes he
is very inappropriate
but i think back to comics complaining
like you won't find a lot of comment oh
he's hilarious yeah
i know who he is uh at the improv he i
did a knife he will say anything too
he's a monster yeah
but uh there's not like a lot of the
successful comics don't say [ __ ]
it's usually the ones who aren't doing
aren't going to sell tickets anyway yeah
and they blame coven you know
yeah yeah dude before code you weren't
moving tickets either by the way
you should feel better you only have to
sell 170 tickets now dude they came and
do those go sell that but they can't do
those yeah yeah i i i like
personally and you do some theaters a
lot of theater you do theaters right
mainly theaters besides covert right
yeah what do you mean
absolutely when the cover hit me and
epson's on the road we were doing the
arenas
first
outside of the money because the money
is different what's your like what size
is your favorite place
and what room good question john my
favorite
theater in the country is uh
it used to be called the verizon now
it's just called the theater in grand
prairie right outside of dallas
because i do new year's eve there every
year so it's just like
it just started as they were they were
done
with music acts and they were like let's
try a comedian one year so like four
years ago we tried it
and we sold about 2 000 seats it sees
about 2000
no it seats 6 500. i did that one now
we're up to 30th and 31st we do
two nights now because it just kept
growing
and now it's like it's got a life of its
own is it you and abs or
just me and then i bring i bring whoever
i want like what's your favorite size
though like what
is that like your energy in eye ideal is
so good that's my favorite theater okay
by far have you shot a special there
mm-hmm the the
this last special we did in san antonio
at the empire theater
i think it was called and then uh i shot
one at the atlanta civic center
i shot one at the stardome in birmingham
i shot one
that place and uh san diego at spreckels
i shot one at the san jose improv how
many specials have you done
probably 12 gangster but i've done three
i did three
i did three or four for bt back in the
day and they were just they were giving
specials out
um i did three or four i did two myself
that i boxed and was selling the road
dvds
then and now they finally got sold years
later and then
how have you done for show time four
yeah four or five
four or five i did bring out the park i
got my associates
uh i agree with myself was the last last
one was on showtime right doing what i
do i did five show time
so doing what i do is the last one
coming and i was getting ready to shoot
my next one in march
and covet hit have you me too i was
supposed to shoot mine at the end of
march have you
have you ever looking back i'm
curious about this just for people who
are so prolific which you
clearly are are there are there any of
your specials out
because there's 12 where you were like
man i wish i had waited another
a year to put that one out yeah there's
a couple are there they're the
the um because because you felt like you
were a better comic a year later or just
that material was can i answer before
you do yeah i wish i waited another five
minutes
hold on like this no i thought that when
i saw brendan
i'm good i'm strange
you should have named that special i
wish i had waited i would yeah
just wait not yet yeah but where were
there any of yours
there was one uh one was um
uh urban legend i called it
and i wish we did san jose improv i wish
i would have weighed it
and i wish i would have just but i was
so like i was like i gotta get something
else out there
i was like i was sick of telling the
jokes that i had been telling for a year
and a half and i got just i just want to
put something out there
and everything just i didn't like the
way i
looked the sound went out i hired
i didn't hire the right people to
because i did it myself to
to do it yeah just spend a little more
money
and got someone that's done it instead
of trying to save money on
cameras and [ __ ] like that by like
hiring somebody else it just it wasn't
it wasn't my favorite set what what do
you think of the the day and age of you
know there's a lot of big comics just
going straight to youtube
we're like i'm good on netflix i'm good
on show time no hbo
yeah i want the maximum people to see it
i'm just going to put it on
youtube well i i'm so big hitters now
doing it i tell all comics now
especially i was like dude
most of the clubs have camera equipment
they can record yeah i go
now i used to be like i don't want to
record i don't like watching myself
or i don't want them having the footage
now i'm like no record everything
because if something happens that isn't
in your act you can throw it on youtube
and if you're monetized make some money
like i was when i did arlington
front row is a chick from germany and
she was with
this guy from cincinnati and they're
inaudible so i had a nice little back
and forth with them for about
eight minutes and we threw it on youtube
yeah i was like this
and it's making money and it's building
your fan base that's the andrew schultz
approach where
he goes out and ho you know he brings
his camera
he has a crew but but you know he know
he's going to go out and do crowd work
and then
the best parts he dices up puts on
youtube and that boy is
moving him all the time tell him he
inspires me
do you know him yeah i did uh i did his
in charlemagne's podcast
and then i did his yeah i did um we went
to some restaurants
that was we went some restaurants i
think you mean the other podcast
he does flagrant and then it wasn't a
podcast it was just me and him
talking oh about the like inside the
comedy basically
yeah yeah yeah but it was uh it was cool
but i met him
i dm'd him after i heard him on rogan
and then i went uh let me i knew he had
the podcast of charlotte maybe i didn't
really follow him but then he started
telling a story then i
started looking him up and i shot him at
dm and just said
i said dude i go i'm a sponge when i see
people taking their
own careers into their own hands and not
relying on anybody else
and i go dude you got me motivated dude
i'm not i know
every big network has tried you know
because he he uh
this isn't i'm not saying anything i
don't think he said but he's supposed to
shoot his specials same time
i think march out here or april out here
sold out like
six theater shows and everything got
shut down
but that you know for that special you
name any big network
they all came after them but i don't
think i got to tell you and i
just from what happened with me when i
put my special on youtube and the way my
page grew
i can't unless and netflix would be the
only one
because netflix really to me you can see
netflix
equals tickets on the road there's no
doubt i disagree but
because if they don't bury you like if
you're tough not get buried because
because you've got to be careful who
they're because if they're going to
release you and it's
with everybody else kevin hart and f you
know these monsters they're like and
josh you're like [ __ ] i i don't think
and honestly i was talking to my manager
about this he goes what are you gonna do
with that special and i said
honestly i would obviously listen
netflix
but i'm not sure i'll ever shoot a
special again
i just might release 20 new minutes of
material
every couple of months to keep my youth
like my youtube page is over a million
subscribers
that is really what keeps my business
going but what else did you do for
business part for sure but as far like
netflix too if
and they have these analytics i've
talked to them where a lot of people
shut off name a comic especially on
netflix
they shut the podcast off i'm sorry the
special offer around 28 minutes
with chappelle burr rogan those big boys
and people come back to it but that's
why they go you should probably put your
clothes in the front now
like bert did that whitney did that they
do something to keep people's attention
because those first first 28 minutes
don't matter who you are
chappelle heart all these guys people
are shut off after 28 minutes i can't
remember they're coming
back but those first twenties so really
you know because the attention span of
people's insane these days
but that's why maybe just release it a
little bit at a time and
and that's what i think i think it's
funny i'm not hating on who's the dude
um
oh black comic he did a it was high
produced mr pryor
hannibal burras oh yeah he released his
during the pandemic and he had it ready
to shoot he shot in miami
and it's a high production that thing
could have been cheap if you watch a
special
and that people wrote all these articles
like oh so inspiring see him take
creative control and drop it here i'm
like dude schultz has been doing this
for a hot second
mark norman sam uh morrow morel
samurail yeah they both release it like
we all
with tommy central though yeah is a
different animal like he changed the
game for the better of everybody
yeah yeah yeah it's the beautiful thing
though about where we are right now and
one of the reasons i feel okay
moving out of l.a and you're out of la
is that
we can we're in control of our own
business now we don't necessarily need
them
and i don't know a whole lot of people
who are comics who are making their
money
because they live in los angeles no i
mean no
right like not at all we're good we're
good i mean we're at a good stage to be
a stand-up because
when we were coming up in the late 90s
you were at the mercy of network execs
yeah somebody's saying
uh we're gonna allow your material to be
seen
now because we all knew those funny guys
in la that just couldn't
sell tickets or couldn't get on the road
like that because they didn't nobody was
[ __ ] with them really now with
youtube you kind of
control your own narrative it's up to
you yeah what is what is
in early on like i remember early on i
did whatever i had to do
to make a little extra like uh i was on
univision
joey diaz called me one week and he was
like hey dog
univision they're looking for comics he
goes can you pretend to be half hispanic
is that k lokos yeah and i go yeah i go
yeah i can be half hispanic and he goes
all right you need to write five minutes
of material about being half jewish half
cuban let's see
so i went down they didn't check me or
anything so i did five minutes about
being half jewish half
cuban and they were like you were great
can you come back and do five more
minutes i'm like no i don't think so
that's all the latin material i got but
i would do anything
to get i went on the gong the the new
god i remember going on the new gong
show
and they said do you want to do your
material and i didn't want to do my
actual material and get gonged
so i pretended to be a character named
uh
david paragamo who was a combination of
two open micros that i started with joe
paragamo and david wright
and i would start i would do one-liners
but i would do david's setup
and joe's punch lines and so i got
gonged in like 20 seconds but i was i
was
creating the audience going to
all the audiences yeah so so i was
creating characters just to get
you also straight into college you also
stripped in college i also stripped in
college but did you
know that did you yeah a couple times
did you do anything
like whatever it takes you kind of stuff
when you were coming up at all
you know i was in the military oh i
didn't know that so i was
in the navy i was on tv and active duty
navy
when i was on bet comic view i took a
week's leave
drove up to l.a because they filmed the
whole season in a week that's why my dad
loved you my dad was in the navy oh
really yeah a good man
that was uh you know we take we take
was it was three or five episodes they
would be t would take three or five
episodes a day monday through friday
so the whole season got filmed in a week
and so i just took a week's leave
and back then it was a contest i kept
winning my rounds
and then they said okay you now you're
gonna get an hour special
so i came back like a month later filmed
my hour special and keep in mind
i probably had 20 minutes it was the
slowest hour
because i'd be like i was walking the
stage like yeah
yeah so when i say i waited till the
last laptop
it was silence and i get the next joke
it was i just remember that clock is
right in front of you and i remember
like
how [ __ ] long is 60 minutes
who else was it were in those
competitions anybody we would recognize
that you competed against uh
that year um i don't know i'll tell you
this i don't know
who i competed against but when i became
the host the next year
that uh if mike epps was on d-ray was on
joe coy was on oh yeah um i wanna say
cat was on but i i'm not positive
but that that that's the thing about bet
they got a
[ __ ] library of legends just sitting
there yeah they're not on youtube
they're not on bet they're just sitting
there do you think by the way
send you a poster joe coy just said do
you think um
because to me kat williams if you've
never seen him live like
he's one of my favorite people to watch
live he
wrecks rooms yeah but why
he has he doesn't translate it to the
white audience
basically at all i mean funny is funny
but what is it you think about cat
why he hasn't translated over because
every time i watch you don't think so
he's so big but if you look
he went crazy but but if you look at
kevin hart's audience when he's selling
tickets
it's a mixture of black and white when
you look at it
why do you think cats take and by the
way not saying cat doesn't sell tickets
cat sales
oh tons of tickets tickets
i mean but why i'm so curious why it
hasn't translated over because
to me man that dude live who
is near non-stop near on his special
when he's in the is the green suit and
he's sweating
this that's every special yeah
look at this oh my god logic
yeah look at michael blackstone at the
bottom
how crazy is that what year is that look
at joe's teeth
joe used to hook me up we used to always
go downtown and he'd uh he had a hookup
with pony and dada
he goes gary come down here just come to
the warehouse and i'd be laced up
at my shows with dallas comics in the
game yeah
for sure but joe was always trying to do
he was
he was the filipino guy yeah and the
black knights yeah you know there was
always like one
race like i always normally the white
guy every now and then somebody else
would pop
up joe was a filipino guy every time
somebody would pop up
i was like there's always somebody
edward san juan would pop up
yeah yeah yeah yeah didn't you win a
best black comic in san diego yeah
yeah that was a radio call in though
like it was
nice i think that a [ __ ] right like
well it wasn't stiff competition
i got there i better win this [ __ ] but
when i say one it wouldn't even [ __ ]
close yeah it went like whoa why'd he
win the crowd was like that white boy
better win yeah
it was it was one of the worst comedy
competitions i've ever been in did you
get kids
yeah i got three how old your kids uh 18
19 and then 28. god do they ever
come on the road with you my son opens
for me every now and then the 28
no the the 19 year old he wants and he
what kind of he don't want to do it he
just has it
he don't want to do it he'll just go and
be like yeah i'm gonna go up tonight
and no and we'll wing it and crush
i'm like this kid he's got the game
oh he just talks about being mixed and
do you do you post them
yeah there's one on youtube his first
set ever is on youtube but do you post
them on instagram
ever no he i don't see much on like i
don't see you posting he doesn't like me
posting them
he's he's he's an odd kid
he's like nah dad don't post me 18 19
and 28.
is it austin or austin what's the 28
year old up to
uh he's in ohio live with his girlfriend
just working all right just doing his
thing
this is dude do you remember gary the
first joke you ever told on stage
i'm always curious son yeah gary's on
austin is gonna watch it all right
chill i don't know it's weird when i
watch myself start sweating
because that pressure's on them to laugh
well you don't think my [ __ ] son's
funny
no
now is the time to get your student loan
payments under control y'all you could
be
saving by refinancing your student loans
with earnest
listen have you ever heard someone go i
love my
high student loan payment oh it's so
great said no one
ever check if refinance with earnest
could help you lower your monthly
payments checking
takes just two minutes your student loan
payment crazy high
all right man if you've been making the
same monthly payment on your student
loans for the last couple years
odds are you could reduce your payment
and save by refinancing
with earnest even if you've done it
before it's all good you can still
refinance again
check your new rate is fast it's easy to
start complete a few questions online
takes about two minutes then you get a
personalized rate estimate
without affecting your credit score so
if you want to lower your monthly
payment man if you want to do it
and you can do it right now you can get
a hundred dollar cash bonus when you
refinance a student loan with earnest
dot com slash fighter terms condition
supply
that's 100 for free when you refinance a
student loan at earnest.com
fighter terms and conditions apply once
again
you get 100 cash bonus when you visit
earnest.com
fighter to refinance your student loan
not available in all states terms
conditions apply visit earnest.com
fighter for more details terms
conditions apply earnest student loan
refinance loans are made by earnest
operations llc and mls
number one two zero four nine one seven
california financing license
number six zero five four seven eight
eight
three zero three second street suite 401
north san francisco california nine four
one zero
seven visit earnest.com licenses for a
full list of full license
states we have to like yeah i mean
oh yeah
that's so funny where is this tommy t's
where i'm at this weekend
before covert this was two years ago and
did he have a plan before he went
out this is like at one o'clock because
i'm gonna go up tonight and this is like
eight o'clock but the huevos on this kid
right
but look at he's like why do you see his
stage friends oh he's like this what's
up
i don't give a [ __ ] i can't imagine
doing that
i'm nervous yeah i am too i'm nervous
for him
he's being cocky goes dad i can do that
i said do it
so he went there he decided while you
were there yeah yeah yeah
and he's is he in school at the house
right here
oh that's two years ago three 17. i
can't believe how old your kids feel
like we're all the same
this is my uh first time doing stand up
so if i'm not funny please
my jokes
currently i'm uh i'm a 17.
i currently live uh in the state of ohio
well we're
moving out here uh this summer i'm gonna
be going
to uh the high school called heritage i
heard a lot i've heard a lot of good
things about it
that's the only thing i told him to do
to get the crowd on your side hype up
the warriors
holy [ __ ] there's so many of you in here
right now
also i don't know what i want to do
after school i kind of want to sit home
and do nothing and play video games
so if there's any sugar mamas or cougars
out there
they're getting
he's got a real solid joke right
[Music]
my dad and you couldn't say that
my dad would do it just felt weird
judy crushed it those are two great
shows sweating he crushed it
you're gone
that's awesome but he was so he looked
so calm
yeah that's just his demeanor he's got
the gift i mean he but he doesn't want
to do it what do you want to do
who knows is he just chilling at home
though yeah that's my biggest fear i'm
like this he's just chilling right now
but we also put a lot of i think in
society we say once you graduate high
school you got to figure out what you
want to do yeah for sure i'm okay with
doing the break year i'd be like let's
just figure it out like
what's your passion what do you want
because he's not a he doesn't want to go
to college
my daughter's in college that's the
route she wants to take i'm cool with it
but
he i always knew but but i think certain
kids are meant for college but then also
when i think back on college when you
get your freshman year and like all
right what are you what's your major
like [ __ ] i don't know
right yeah titties what do you want me
to do i get to decide right now what i'm
gonna do for the next four years
my youngest son didn't go to college he
came back and he was just like yeah
that's not for me
and i i was like fine fine man yeah and
he's doing he's doing great but
schools do that they they need to put
the stress uh chase your passion
not trace education chase education yeah
chase your passion whatever that is i
know what i mean
you know what also though i think you
have to sometimes chase your passion and
also like
embrace what you're good at some people
are almost embarrassed by what they're
good at so they try to do something it'd
be okay to fail at it yeah you know what
i'm saying like
chase it it doesn't work out all good
college ain't going nowhere
but also with you both your kids thank
god they have dads like you because
like my dad was like nah [ __ ] you're
getting education you can play football
in your education like all right i guess
that's what i'm gonna do yeah but but
you know i felt like
that college was actually gonna make my
son feel bad about himself
because he was he the classroom was not
his but the classroom is not his thing
right and he he his attention is a
little sketchy
and so he always would leave school
feeling stupid and he's a smart kid
yeah but he would leave school feeling
stupid and i'm like this is not
i'm not setting him up to succeed it's
not for him i'm putting him in a
situation that makes him feel bad about
himself
so why am i doing it but your other uh
two kids are in college
one's done 28 if you're 28 and still in
college
yeah he's he's got your brother you
could be a doctor daughter
our daughter just got we just took her
there three weeks ago uh
north carolina a t in greensboro hbcu
yeah i knew that going in i i said it i
talked it into my act like five years
ago i did a special oh my daughter's
going to historically black college
cause she's
she doesn't want to be white at all
everything goes wrong in her life is my
fault
it's sunburned it's your fault dad melon
in my skin
sorry
all my black friends are just out at the
pool enjoying themselves
being very aloe vera and each other [ __ ]
sorry my bad
my
what is the problem what are you mad
about
yeah oh of course swimming in your
[ __ ] backyard
oh my god man but let me ask you
something when you when i was growing up
dude that sunburn
we used to use baby oil i don't know
what we were doing that was to enhance
it
baby oil yeah that's the turn yeah
that's to enhance the tan oh you know we
got babylon
that's what the people did that was
getting to yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying you would
lay out what you need afterwards you put
that baby oil on man
that really increased the tank oh yeah
but also a little bit of the paint
yeah yeah it baby only attracts the heat
a little bit you and i tan
gary not so much no no do you freckle
i don't know i just he doesn't look like
i don't go out yeah
are are any of your kids darker than the
other is there one real white like you
my daughter my daughter's fair skinned
like me
not like me but you know she's the
lightest one of the whole family
and she's the one that cares most about
her color
where the the boys don't give [ __ ] yeah
they can care less but my daughter's one
like
i identify as a black woman yeah i'm
black there's no doubt there's just no
doubt right yeah she's i went on a
black lives matter march with her
where'd she get the megaphone i don't
know
400 years of oppression
dude when that megaphone came out i go
what is going on right now where did you
get it first of all
making valid points yeah it was just
loud yo
where'd you come from uh i got tear
gassed at one of the
down here in la really oh yeah were you
marching or you were just there
were you were you losing
i'm saying there's marches but then
somebody you might have been coming at
starbucks oh yeah
and you're like hey man hey man
hey man that's how you talk to me cops
i was i was it was down uh on beverly
boulevard
and um i came home and i told my wife
i'm like hey there's a protest down
there i'm going down
this is in the thick of it like this
second day and she was like don't go
down there and i said yeah but i've
this is where i have this is where we
have to be like and so i went down
and you heard uh
and i was like oh no and gas started
going and i thought i should run away
from that gas
but then i thought i've never been tear
gas before did party go out this how bad
can it be yeah yeah and so i walked into
it
i just was like i know i'm not going to
die oh my gosh let's see what it feels
like you're the crazy ass white dude i
just wanted to see
because i just wanted to see what it was
like it was not great
my face was just dumping out
my eyes [ __ ] was coming out my nose
people and i didn't know that they were
pouring milk on me
because i guess that works better than
water yeah so
late i'm just wipe it all off and i
walked back to my house but later in the
day
all day i'm like something smells like
terrible oh cause the milk dried
there was just milk behind my ears oh
dried up did you walk in the door your
wife was like told you dumbass yeah
yeah she was like you're so [ __ ] dumb
yeah but but but honestly like
those kind of things i'm not an
adrenaline junkie but if you're like hey
you want to try this
one time most anything you know i told
you i ate that live cockroach yeah
if if you're going to ask me if i'm
going to try it
over there hey man you've been to your
guest
no ever do it in boot camp yeah that's
right we got to get some boot camp
because you have to
guys you take the mask off and then
there's this
big um uh not vent you're outside but
that's where you spit and let the
slobber and snot come out you're just
standing there
but i remember you stand there and you
got your gas mask on
and you line up and if you don't put
your gas max on right
it hits you as soon as you walk in so a
couple guys didn't put it on right
so they're already freaking the [ __ ] out
right i don't know and then they say
okay other caliber take your mask off so
we gotta take it off we hold it over our
heads
and just want to hold together and they
come by they ask they ask you a question
it's a simple question it's like uh what
what comes after the number two you know
three
simple i'll never forget the guy next to
me could not
talk and they go what's fred
flintstone's wife's name
and i'm sitting there going it's [ __ ]
wilma it's [ __ ]
wilma and the guy actually just he's
just like
just going holy [ __ ] dude
that could because i've heard of some
guys just it doesn't affect them right
all right
i didn't see that they're like yeah it's
the same guys like you see them get
tased and they just kind of take the
pink blank and take it out you're like
oh my father-in-law was a cop and i was
asking we were watching
one of those uh recent videos where that
gentleman was shot seven times
but they tried tasting them i go how the
what a gangster like the taste doesn't
work yes
some people it just doesn't work if it's
a bigger guy he goes like we we probably
won't even try and taste you because
you're so big
you can probably just rip them off and
keep charging at it it what about
really could it get caught in the
clothes though too like it died
he says for some people it could be he
was saying for some people it just
doesn't work
so then when they shoot the things if
those don't work you get close yeah it
has the ability to
go straight to the neck but i heard that
the tase works better
and i could be 100 wrong no if you're
wet definitely
but if you're low body fat that it
travels better through muscle
is what i maybe that's a hundred percent
fat geyser
so like if you're like if you're like a
thin dude with very little body fat
that's what i heard it could be 100
wrong did you ever do the shreveport
funny bone
yeah so i get tangled in the day i get
tased down there
by the staff by the remember the cops in
the orange vests
that used to walk around that area they
told them it was like an initiation i
feel like they just [ __ ] but you know
you literally like between me you and
eddie griffin
you the third person has had an issue
with security and stuff at that club
because i i came in like the third week
they were open
right and that was the one it was it
wasn't like a normal corporate one
no the these brothers built it
so i'm talking about the club and i'm
just like a comedian like there was a
fish tank there was a saints helmet on
stage
yeah i'm making fun of club it's
literally at the end of the week guy
goes
hey man i might be a little city go hey
hey man
i might be a little sensitive here
he said but uh you kind of went hard on
the club this week man and me and my
brother we built this from our bare
hands and i go
what you build a comedy club
because i don't know man just maybe i'm
a little sensitive right now i go yeah
yeah
i literally looked at the lineup and i
go oh [ __ ] i got andy griffin next week
oh
i go here ain't gonna make it through
the week they told me eddie griffin got
dragged out by
security damn like they they came at him
and dragged him out and i go
this guy thinks i'm bad yeah eddie's
coming no oh my god then you're telling
me you guys
but they tased you because they told me
initiation headlining comic gets tased
after saturday night late show who said
that
the brothers the baby i guess i guess
they got hit
yeah chasing all these [ __ ] yeah
it was it was an uncomfortable situation
but that club
in general was a bit of a [ __ ] show is
it still there is it
not there no i don't think it lasted a
year um maybe a little more
you know titus married the woman who
ended up running it and turning it
around a little bit
oh really yeah yeah because that first
year it was
i think i was the i had to be first
month it was open no it smelled new the
woods smell there's still a few dicey
clubs out there
that are newer like the st louis helium
gets a little dicey because they just
opened
a new one no one i'm there in three
weeks i'm sure for you it might
be fine now i was there early on i
remember joey diaz called me
i was like get ready man they they
they're they just don't that it's the
first comedy club they've had
and it's just they don't know how to act
so people can be talking
you can get heckled i'm like no joey
come high crowd no sure enough
yeah he's not really oh dude nightmare
and the in the
security there they're just they might
as well bought tickets they just watched
the show and they started heckling dude
goddamn
i it was in nashville and by the way
that nashville zanes is one of my
favorite
the best dorfman is one of my favorite
people
well one weekend i'm there but their
security
isn't exactly big it's not big tough
dudes you know what i mean yeah
so one weekend there's a guy there big
old country dude
and uh he's there with this girl and
he's being loud
and i'm i'm trying to just get past it
but i'm gonna i gotta go in on him
and i go in on him and his girlfriend
laughs at him and as soon as his
girlfriend laughs at him
he's pissed yeah and he starts going in
and he starts to stand up
and starts to go [ __ ] start
talking about [ __ ] this and i'll
shove that microphone and i look at
security and security's out
when you're on stage at zany's if you
look to your left right
that back hallway leads you to the green
room security was standing like this
looking at me on stage and i looked at
him and he just slowly went behind the
wall like that
and i was like oh no i hate when i walk
in the club
i get it all the time security guys oh
easy weekend for us
anybody [ __ ] with you you're gonna [ __ ]
them up oh my god but i'm not though
dude yeah yeah i'm not i'm trying to
stand up can you do your job i'll do
mine yeah right i'm not trying to fight
anybody dude hysterical they all
every single one it's the first joke
yeah oh easy night for us dude you got
this like but i don't know yeah yeah
i don't did you ever do in baltimore
what was it the comedy fact i do all the
time
downtown it's one of the oh no no no no
no you know the horrible comedy fact are
you talking about the old improv right
no no the one downtown that was owned by
the the dude who who was at the comedy
he was he was on the radio and his
brother ran the place
uh oh you're talking about the is that
the rock station
yeah but it was down okay clearly i've
thrown out three things but then you
shut them all down no but the one the
one downtown
one was a power plant you said it was
that in the power plant yeah
and the one upstairs in the power in the
yeah that was the improv though
dude that place had
massive security and they would drag
people out middle
of the in the middle of your show
literally dragged this the other
security takes a job too seriously yes i
was like hey hey hey hey
and it was i guess the guy mouthed off
to security and like they
who and picked this dude up and
literally dragged him out middle of the
show some of the security has the the
the you know the wire they have the
earpiece
and look yeah like dude you if you're
worried about somebody you just say
you say say tyson give me some water i'm
gonna [ __ ] that dude up like
all right man don't want that i don't
think we need that dude i think people
are here to have a good time yeah
you're also sick do you ever do the uh
evansville indiana funny bone
you know when people ask what's your
favorite yeah if you asked me my worst
that's it it's easy yes really and i
gave it two chances
easy yes like out of control it was just
the audience was so bad i i've never
seen such a segregated
city an audience in my life really
because i'd be out
and every now and then i'd see a black
person and they'd recognize me and then
i
talked about yeah i'm at the fireman
like oh we don't [ __ ] with that place i
was like what
and then because it's like a white
establishment they just didn't want to
they didn't bring a lot of urban acts
one and then
it was it was the oddest thing man uh i
go up there the first night
the host doesn't get laughs the feature
doesn't get laughs and i go oh it's
gonna be a long night
so i'm up there like 20 minutes i didn't
get a chuckle yet come on and i
literally went
hey and all the guys got bellies and
they're sitting like this
there's a center and then i go hey guys
um
i don't know why you came here tonight i
said but larry the cable guy
is not walking through the door
literally a guy goes
whoa those are big shoes buddy
and i went wow that's the most reaction
i got
all week yeah there it is yeah what's
that oh no that's uh
i thought you were answering the
question half an hour ago like what then
i'm talking about
then uh i'm i'm still hustling merch
[ __ ] it
so i'm out there trying to hustle my
dvds right i'm selling like one a show
you know now the price is down to ten
dollars oh so i had a boston
celtics warm-up jersey on and this guy
comes out and goes
i like that shirt how much you pay for
it i was like oh
60 bucks i'll give you 80. i went dude
[ __ ] you that's my bonus for the weekend
but here's what made the club the worst
when i landed uh into evansville the
manager picked me up she tried to take
me to a days inn
it was and it was the first 48 days in i
go
oh i'm not staying here and i called my
manager i said they're trying and she's
in the car i go
they what's my contract say cause
they're trying to put me to days in
and how long ago is this gary 2005
okay right you're way past days in yeah
yeah
days and days are over yeah so i was
like this uh so there's one marriott on
evansville
by the airport and literally sits in a
field by itself
and i go they go she takes me out of the
marriott now she's pissed the whole
drive over
right so i'm trying to like ease
everything now like trying to talk to
her but she's not having it
she tasted the marriott so i tell her
hey i'm kind of hungry
hint can we stop and get something to
eat she goes well if you want to stay
the day's in there's a wind he's right
across the street
we'll see you tonight took off what the
[ __ ]
i'd eat room service all week [ __ ] i was
like this that is just stuck
and it didn't have a restaurant it was
attached to a sandwich shop
so you you got you didn't get free food
the sandwiches were half off
i was like oh do you do you
and i when i went to one club and i
won't i don't want to put them on blast
but i remember state though so i know
tennessee and when i got there he was
like
okay so just so you know comics get half
off food i go stop right there
i said you you want us to pay for food
and he was like yeah about half off i go
no no no no no i go
what is it he goes well i found comics
for taking advantage of the kitchen and
getting two plates of food i'm like
jesus really nice
i said i told him i go hey man just so
you know
i go have you had a lot of people not
come back he goes most i go yeah
yeah most people are i think about that
i won't say the name we've all been
there we all love the club where
at the end of the you know sat last show
saturday night
they took out the drinks i had on stage
and
that my my brother's my magic my brother
we always drink whiskey
i'm like whiskey who the [ __ ] they tried
to tell me off
air see if i was an experience yeah yeah
man
i don't have it i don't have any like
and then we went out we went out with
that man
with the man we went out with the
manager to because he's like oh let me
take you guys to dinner because i think
he knew cause i was like what the [ __ ] i
will never be back if you're trying for
drinks it's ridiculous
let me take you out to dinner and my my
opener my feature both
black the black guys right and he
dropped the n-word in front of him no
so this is definitely not a corporate
it's not an improv double down
no i did it and i was like oh and
you know me my brother i was like uh
what i go what the
[ __ ] dude and he was like yeah you know
how it is maybe somehow no we don't know
how it is and then we were like no
no one does no we were like we literally
we have no idea what you're talking
about
do you know the only owner that i knew
would drop
any word in front of me and you were
almost just like whatever man was craig
glazer
from city of the city stanford this dude
was the most
casual racist
he was saying words with nothing on him
he was the
most casually racist the first time i
ever
okay the very first time i ever met him
i'm coming in from the airport
i'm with my suitcase and he goes hey
come in here
and i go into his room and craig laser
dude is notorious he was a
thief his sometimes his wig was crooked
and backwards like this [ __ ]
so um he comes i come into office and he
was just
a gross dude and um there's a girl
sitting on the other side of his desk
and he goes hey i go yeah he goes you
[ __ ] teenagers i go what
what hey man
and he goes he goes he goes do you [ __ ]
teenagers i go no i don't [ __ ] teenagers
yeah and he goes you don't [ __ ]
teenagers i go do you think that makes
me the weird one
yeah like do you are you judging me you
think i'm the odd man out of the
[ __ ] like i don't know i go no i
don't
i don't [ __ ] teenagers and he goes he
looks like he goes he goes she's legal i
go yeah
jesus stop it right there you stop it
right there this guy
only had sex with black strippers and he
paid them
and so but he used to he played me this
message this
back-to-back message this stripper was
going off because he was a little behind
on payments
and she was laying into you small
dick crooked hair mother like this
entire
and he goes he stops right then he stops
semester he looks at me he goes
so you think she likes me and she's just
mad or i go no dude
she just wants her money bro he was like
yeah i just i just
i really wanna like me i'm like she's uh
hooker bro yeah dude like what do you
think is happening he's in love with
money
yeah right he passed away he passed away
man he's gonna say
he was a crazy you do you know his story
when he was growing up
so he was a straight-up thief and then
he figured out a way
to get over on drug dealers he he
he got a crew together and part of the
crew were the people buying the drugs
and the other part of the crew were fake
fbi people
so they would bring all this money and
these drugs and then people would bring
drugs and they would
come in as fake fbi take the drugs and
the money is this ozark season three
this is a hundred percent
not that the name of his book is called
the king of sting
oh damn so then he got busted by the fbi
but the fbi said
hey you're getting meetings
with drug dealers that we can't find
how are you doing this you come work for
us
be an art or we put you in jail and he
was like i'll work for you
he could only stay straight for about
six months and then just started double
dipping on the fbi
jesus and ended up doing time in jail
his partner
who um he used to do these with got why
he watched him get shot here in l.a
dude this dude's story is banana i think
the book is called king of sting king
but man this guy did you ever do his
club yeah all the time because he passed
away
he yeah just of old age or uh i think he
had
yeah modern day i think he ended up with
cancer is what happened
but uh you asked the kansas city comics
like chris porter and these guys they
were like that is the [ __ ] worst guy
ever that's him
that's him man damn yeah so he just
he died what three years ago yeah
something um there yeah leukemia he was
he had been banned
when he drove you around to do press in
the morning in kansas city
he couldn't walk into any of the radio
stations or that he had been banned from
all
him in there he'd been banned from all
the buildings he's been banned from it
yeah they're great places he's rubbed
shoulders with comedians like robin
williams
yeah he would be he would
introduce you like people didn't have
google he'd be like
coming to the stage next this guy has
done 20 tonight shows and you're
backstage like dude
like come on man yeah one of his credits
for me was he created chelsea lately i'm
like this is
[ __ ] this is not what
you did chelsea lately a lot yeah i
think i did over 200 of them
did you do it no i got a pretty good
chelsea handler story though that's what
you got
uh there's yeah
and sometimes the wig was sideways were
you like man that's that's backwards
i think so yeah yeah yeah he was banana
look at that picture by the way
that's just him an all black yeah his
favorite was this girl he called black
barbie
he yeah he was all what a character uh
his book dude yes and he used to ask you
what do you mention
that must have been right after that
teenager left
[Music]
away all his money this dude was insane
but
a story you know one of those guys that
was highly inappropriate
and you either loved him or you hated
him but i haven't i had a soft spot for
him just because
he was unapologetically himself yeah do
you know what i mean
i liked him he like i heard he did dirty
[ __ ] to people but he never
i know it sounds like he never ripped me
over yeah never ripped me off or got
over on me or nothing
yeah he was a bananas the last time he
tried to but that's your experience you
know what i'm saying like a lot of
people want to judge like ellen
or name name anybody who's in the
spotlight or you know these
comics it's like a lot of times i hear
all these awful stories but my
experience with them has been great so
it's like
i can't [ __ ] on them i can't dog pile on
with you man yeah i've had great
experiences
well and for for craig i actually
was okay with some of the bad because i
like
weirder people who can tell me crazy
stories yes
so sitting down with him for a night you
were gonna hear it's never an
easy uh whenever you sunday you're going
to get paid
no it wasn't ever five minutes no it's
45 minutes later you're still talking to
craig about some [ __ ] yeah i got someone
so coming next weekend
yeah yeah i think we just booked so yeah
you want to do some voices on my
animation
he's got these posters he had one boxing
documentary he goes yeah i did that and
he explained it i go i didn't ask
yeah yeah yeah i got a flight to catch
dude yeah yeah yeah you know you know
that's just george foreman let me tell
you about do it for me
there's some managers too that there's
some managers get a little too cozy
yeah they try to jump in with the crew
and then oh where you guys going after
this and they go with you
and then the green room all the time
chilling it's like come on dude
you know what i'll pick up the vibe of
the room man 100 beat it nerd
if there's somebody in there i don't
want in there i say something no i just
start farting
oh wow i'm i'm a dick are you a dick
i don't they say their face but i i call
ahead and i go
i don't want anybody in the green room
when i go in there because i don't
know your crew like yeah i go i don't
want to walk in and then there's a guy i
don't know sitting there
cuz i'm particular i'm a little
superstitious i'm with it i like the
left side of the couch
so now i got this guy sitting there
looking at me that's that's what i said
sorry did you not get the memo now your
ass has made
i like a cold yeah yeah yeah i like this
or they went
up they grabbed the water got the no
this sense is mine
you got you got the circle by the way
it's yours is there anything worse
warm toilet seat is there anything worse
than you
you're in public and you just have to go
and you sit down you're like
the seats warm like the four times i've
probably taken a [ __ ] in public in my
life only four
yeah i that i don't think this story has
been it's clean
i take everything i wipe the soap down i
think i purel it everything everything
and then i kind of hover it's never like
a full section oh yeah
oh i don't you cry i freeze up though
somebody walks in the bathroom like
yeah [ __ ] i don't wanna i don't think
they hear the plop
something like this self-conscious
damn it would you [ __ ] get going man
why so you don't like to are you afraid
to poop in public no
don't give a flying [ __ ] yeah germaphobe
none of that
i mean for me the the the the
airport bathroom is a place that i try
to avoid just because
if it's just generally not the cleanest
but i'm with you man
you don't care at all no game on planes
i don't give a [ __ ] planes
planes on the planes i try to hurry no i
don't want this because stewart's always
right next to the door
so i don't want to be like dookie boy so
i hurry
and then i wash my hands to get the
smell of the soap then i open the door
do you ever time it you're like this is
how long a piss could take so
i'm gonna i'm gonna make sure i'm not in
here longer than if i'm
there long then i'll pretend i'm on my
phone which doesn't make sense now
because of the huh yeah i'm in the air
okay
the flight attendant's like why does
your phone smell like [ __ ]
i always rub my hands when i come out of
the bathroom yeah people know i washed
them yeah everything
like this
[Laughter]
yeah i like to wear when i go to the
bathroom a plane taking [ __ ] i'll rub my
hands i'll pretend i forgot so i'm like
what the
[ __ ] i have to tell you i am
anti-pooping on planes you shouldn't
poop on tour buses you shouldn't poop on
airplanes
for me if it's an emergency i get it but
if i can hold it i don't get out of my
seat on the plane i don't pee
i i pee before i get on the plane i lean
up against the window and i go to sleep
the worst if you got a window
and the guy next to you just takes the
tray down his laptop and everything like
this
ah if i got a piss he's not gonna be
happy yeah
i apologize like ten times sorry i got
it me too i'm sorry
and then finally you know i'll just tell
like and they're like
but then you're stuck you don't want to
get them twice though i know i just i
gotta
i'll i'll hold it so i can't hold it
anymore because i just want to get up
once i don't want to bother this dude
twice
it's so stressful yeah you have to say
it's a stressful situation like
sending emails
like right there he's about to transfer
the money from his 401k
excuse me yeah i i i my stock just went
down [ __ ]
yeah are you a chatty kathy on the plane
no man
i have headphones in seven ends a a's
and ends no man
i don't want you talking to me my
headphones are in my my
my hoodie's on and and that's i just
don't
i'm not ready for small talk i'm going
to be saying
i just don't want to do it the energy
the worst is when they go
where you headed yeah same place you are
bro we're on the same plane
no i don't i hate telling them what i do
oh yeah because if you say comedian
nothing they say
you only get three responses it's either
they try to tell you a joke that's
long or they want you to tell them a
joke
or they ask you do i do you know
somebody and we're the only profession
they do that
because it's i always say like you'll
say i'm a comedian and you know frank
smith from milwaukee yeah
like this how how would i be on tv or
anything no no he's a local guy
how the [ __ ] yeah they don't go up to
lebron james
you know david jackson basketball the
ymca in torrance yeah that guy's a beast
on tuesday night
no how would i know him we bought my
basketball that guy's a beast
dude the third in overleague yeah he
sets the pick at the elbow
you see this jumper yeah a set no yeah
you started orange county i was in
torrance
well they either asked someone like
really like low like that or like
what do you think kevin hart man funny
right yeah yeah yeah sure dude
the worst thing they tell you a joke
yeah and you're just going how long is
this joke and you got you always
getting the fake laugh the long jokes
are rough
you know what else is rough dude when
they try to tell you somebody else's
joke that you know is funny you know
you know kevin hart's joke and they tell
you this butchered i'm like are you
telling people that's kevin hart's joke
because that was not it like that's the
[ __ ] worst thing
i i will tell you though man or or they
go do if you're flying to kansas city
you can't see we playing that
bro maybe i'll go maybe you know what
maybe we'll go
friday and saturday yeah man [ __ ] yeah
and super awkward they're sitting right
next to you like can i get a couple
tickets and i'm like i don't want to say
no right to your face but
no yeah or or or they go or they go so
how would i go about getting tickets
like like any other
[ __ ] god are you talking about this
we talk about something else dude
my my so i'm at tommy t this weekend my
opener
i live an hour for the san francisco
airport he goes hey man uh
can i ask him real quick yeah he goes
what's the most efficient way he's
that's what he said what's the most
official way to get to your house
from the san francisco airport i go do
you need a ride
is that what you're asking like that's
like a passive dresser
this is someone else's car is that what
you mean that's why i said again i
assume he's like kind of scared of gary
not physically but just like you know
because you're
a famous comic he's probably yeah hey
dude you know like that's his way of
beating around the bush yeah like this
just uber or bart or i don't know
i always say this real friends don't ask
friends pick him up from the airport or
help him move
like you know come on dude yeah come on
man not after a certain age
no you're you're 20 years old what yeah
i can't go there
what no dude hour from my house that's
an hour back to it's two hours out of
town
and we got a show that night there's
zero zero chance that's happening what
was it i
always talking about chelsea i got it
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah so chelsea
handler i got a p after the story i'm
like the guy on the plane you're in the
middle seat
it's a long story it's like your first
step
yeah i like that so chelsea h
you guys know her right but you said i
never did a show here's what's funny
i've always been a little bitter
within myself not anybody else like gosh
i should have been on that show
because i'll tell you why she opened for
me
at the sacramento uh punch line
and she was getting ready to montreal
the next week great club and
she she had been working and i i'd been
where she'd been she was
she gave her new faces i think yeah so i
did it the year before and i
bombed at new faces and she was like um
she was thursday night she's pissed she
goes what the [ __ ] she's at the bar and
she's
like pounding these drinks right and i
go what's wrong and she goes
i'm doing montreal next week and this
[ __ ] set's been working
and it's not working right now but my
audience is not montreal's audience
so i told the club i go this is gonna
sound racist i go
blacks and mexicans in the back put all
the older white people in the front
i go because i and i told her i said
focus on the front
yeah we're going to put all the blacks
in the latinos in the back of the room
we're going to put
it's not a big room as it is yeah focus
on the first two rows man
and her set got the audience was better
as the week went on right
and then i just remember she was she
dropped me off at the residence inn
she had a volkswagen and she dropped me
off and i wished her good luck in
montreal and i said you're gonna be good
i said you're
you're attractive i said you got like
this um you got an attitude about you
i said they're gonna eat you up montreal
you'll be fine and then she went
as i i'm acting like her agent you'll be
fine
then she went uh i just remember going
are you where are you staying she goes
i'm driving back guys you drive back to
ellie now
it's like midnight yeah i'm just gonna
drive back i said
all right and she took off and then she
got the deal and got the show and i
always
remember going i put the blocks in here
i look out for you i root it for you and
i can't get on
one [ __ ] episode
i gave you the encouragement to kill
montreal oh my god i gave you your push
out of the nest baby
whatever she has to remember i guarantee
she does but i've been to the sacramento
punch line because the year before i had
did new faces and
[ __ ] bombs i never did you think the
set didn't go
it's the last time i didn't trust my gut
because i was with
caa at that time and at that time people
were leaving there with
big holding deals right yeah and they
were grooming all these networks
to come see me and they go don't worry
about the audience reaction you're just
trying to get your point of view across
because we're basing a show off this set
this five minute set dude by the way i
remember that period of comedy
when your manager and agent were just
like what's your pov give me f
give me your point of view in five
minutes tell me tell them who you are so
they can make a show about you there was
a
about a two year period where yeah
that's where they get developmental data
big money and they were just grooming
you they were like just get five minutes
together don't worry about
hours or 20 minutes they just wanted you
to get five minutes together i remember
that
when i and i went up and i remember don
barrera hosted
they didn't really laugh at dom and i'm
first
i'm the first guy it's new faces i'm the
first guy it's 6 p.m and it was daylight
i remember going i looked in the
audience it was old white like i
literally saw a lady with blue hair it
was like
oh and they didn't like dumb here's
here's
the story i got later so i went up there
i didn't get
nothing in five minutes and i got off
stage and right before i walked on stage
i looked at my age and i go
i'm gonna switch my setup i go there
they're not gonna get the five minutes
i'm talking about it goes no no no
stick to the five minutes got the
networks here don't worry about the
laughs yikes but you know we feed off
energy
yeah flat i got off stage i went out the
back door of the club
my hotel is about two miles away i
started walking back cussing the whole
way my wife
wasn't even that wasn't my girlfriend at
the time she's like a hundred yards
behind me she knows a man go [ __ ]
because in my brain you knew i was like
i didn't go to any parties the next two
days because i had two days before i
went up again
i thought everybody's like that's got a
bomb that's got a bomb i didn't do
anything they would invite me hey
everybody's getting together like nope
nope nope i watched more cfl football
in two days i ever watched in my life i
knew all the montreal
[ __ ] alouettes or whatever it was
that's right so
two days later i show up for the second
new faces showcase and now
i got a new five minutes i'm like okay
i'm ready tonight find out everybody
bombed
all eight comics that audience [ __ ]
sucks oh really
everybody ate it but it didn't make me
feel any better which set did you do
the second one the one you had done
initially or the new one
no the second set was just about
montreal five minutes about the
city and i walked around for two days
and got to know [ __ ] and it crushed
right it was good i wouldn't say crushed
it was good yeah
but i ended up getting a holding deal
because guy tori missed his flight
and the urban show i had to they asked
me to stay an extra night and fill in i
go
yeah i can do that yeah and that's the
night i killed and i got a holding deal
with quincy jones
because quincy saw all four of my sets
oh wow he goes yo he goes i went i saw
your sets
he goes you didn't do well the first
night you adjust it
did better the second night he goes and
then when you did the urban shows you
did two
first show you did clean the second show
you went dirty because that's what they
told us
and i was like he goes so i saw you
adjust you did four different sets
four different but it's only five
minutes i did 20 minutes still dude
that's
that's to do four different sets and to
have the balls to do four different sets
especially at that time when all of our
people were telling you
if you want to make it you got to make
it in montreal like there was so much
pressure to do that
and the fact that you had the balls to
ditch that first set that you had been
working on the whole time and just do
three is is huge yeah
yeah yeah you know what i mean you're
right he's a monster yeah
but do you think the like fresh faces
the new faces like jfl
it's not as big anymore right no they're
not handing out the deals remember that
deal mitch hedberg got and we were all
a big deal oh mitch got something like a
750
000 million dollar deal was it what year
was that
man uh earlier 2000 i know callan got a
big deal too
yeah remember a guy chicken
chicken by the way that was the same
year oh that was your year yeah he got a
dude
he got a big deal huge yeah he he only
had five minutes yes
but i was there that night where i he
got the deal and it was crazy
because for whatever reason the audience
was a little flat and the comic before
him
was low energy monotone in fact the two
three comics before him
and he went up yeah and he he did this
music bit where you start
grinding on this old lady it was kind of
hacky but
that night the stars aligned and the old
lady was with it
so she like put her hand on his ass and
she was in the crowd start going [ __ ]
nuts yeah
and he walked out of there he got a
[ __ ] huge deal
yeah dude and it way before he was ready
for it too they kept
you know what i mean do you do any of
the like i remember
obviously i just came up different so
jfl they've been asking me to do it for
like four years i'm like no
i mean how much money now i'll just go
up there and do my own show why would i
be part of this it's not about
the money yeah yeah so that i finally
did it last year for the first time and
my agent was like dude i'm telling you
they keep asking
go up there and do it you know your
theater is gonna be next to birds like
your friends are going to be there it's
not about it's not a money play just go
up there
this one time if you don't like it you
won't ever have to again i went up there
like oh i get it yeah it's dope you're
on all the comics
jump on the other shows hanging out the
comic parties like it made sense
but they were telling me like you got to
realize like what you're talking about
they go back in the day
if someone had a good set it made their
career yeah really like
oh launching power but what you're
describing about jfl
is really what i missed the most about
the comedy store and all the other
places being down
i love hanging around with comics it's
my favorite well thank god we have this
podcast
without a doubt but i miss the comedy
store and i miss the improv or the laugh
factory
where you're just upstairs with people
that you
there's something about talking with
comics there's an energy and there's
well that's like
i'm doing it i was telling gary before
this like my agent called me was like
dude bad news about
uh cap city in austin you know it's
supposed to be whatever 180 they're
going
down 115 we should just move it till
next year i'm like now
i need that man i need to hang out with
other comics the stage time like yeah
i'm good man we'll just add more shows
yeah i i need that man what's the
motherfucker's doing this chappelle's
camp
yeah he's bringing like i was telling
him i gotta ask to do it this weekend
i go dan asked me a short notice and
it's hard to say no but
uh i said i could do it any other
weekend just i've already like added
shows and stuff i don't want to cancel
yeah 10 shows yeah i don't want to
cancel
your show sounds dope when i get out of
here i'm like hey what's up yeah
i'm going to ask you about that and
they're starving i mean not that i i
mean i sell tickets but
even me i'm like whoa these are some way
faster than normal
also that's an easy light too easy
flight but i love the headphones i'm
gonna i'm gonna
send me a video because i said i gotta
see what i don't understand it really i
wanna make sure and i
when i saw the videos up i go oh okay
this is gonna work
and everybody was laughing and they get
they pan the audience and they got
the headphones on i go we'll be dope if
they go english to spanish
you could really cross that audience
yeah you're smart
let me did i just come up with a great
idea yeah you did yeah yeah i can't
believe how good i am let me take a piss
and do current events sir
yeah i got to jet at 2 15. okay we are
also brought to you by on its
supplements on it.com
fighter for 10 off the entire damn site
alpha brain new mood you got uh total
gut health earth grown nutrients
protein powder krill oil joint oil what
do you want to do man you want fitness
gear i gotcha kettlebells they're hard
to find right now go to onit.com
10 off kettlebells primal bells uh
kettlebell sets zombie bells how about
you on on demand training streaming
fitness
from your frickin crib man or your hotel
room you can do it all with body weight
we got kettlebell workouts on at six
on demand streaming fitness steel club
maces quad
maces battle ropes whatever you want man
we got gear
we got freaking krill oil we got on
demand training kettlebells they got it
all
on it.com slash fighter 10 off you want
some of the best coffee
you got the [ __ ] yeah coffee it's black
rifle collabed with on it
they have freaking calf caffeine
crystals in this dark roast it's my
favorite coffee on the planet
[ __ ] yeah coffee black rifle on it doing
the damn thing on it.com
fighter what do you got jen all right
first one
have you guys seen this photo of adele
yeah yeah so this photo is going viral
and a lot of people had a lot of
different feelings about it
a lot of people came out and said that
they were offended that she was cultural
appropriating jamaican culture and then
a bunch of people who were jamaican came
out and basically said shut up unless
you're jamaican
she's at the notting hill festival
that's just what they do to celebrate
that culture
and adele's doing nothing wrong a couple
days later
your favorite person ever chet hanks
came out and posted this video
shooting at his boy shooting his shot
with adele yes
adele adele adele
you're not sending me a prayer from a
long time but after me see a picture one
[Music]
first of all it's tough being tom hanks
son let's just yeah man it's also tough
your dad's force gump it's a tough go
but that doesn't mean you have to wear
jean shorts with white socks pulled up
like there's no excuse for that
you know what i mean like i don't know i
don't care whose son you are
jean shorts with your white socks pulled
up that's it's not your look it's a
tough
[ __ ] goat he's entertaining to me he
dude he's super entertaining yeah
there's no doubt
that jamaica that he's a white rapper
yeah
always a rapper i do you have a problem
with what adele was wearing
i don't yeah i don't either right no i
mean
it's no different than uh you see people
wearing the
british flag or the american flag yeah
man
trust me there's worse things to be mad
about yeah this ain't it
don't don't put point your negativity i
would be more mad at the jeans and the
white socks than i would be at the
bikini i think i think
but but this dude man i love his a
hundred percent confidence and
commitment
100 to this like he's what do you think
what happened
right that's why he took his shot she's
single now she lost all that weight and
ditched homeboy what what uh
i think she got divorced and then i
think you think what kind of game you
think chet hanks has
if adele calls chet hanks i bet he's
pretty smooth criminal again when your
dad's tom hanks
you're going to have some chops you want
me my dad
that's the bad that would be my life too
dad yeah i want to come over and see my
dad
here put this on i got the the bottom
half of splash
come on what do you mean i didn't want
to be my dad too that's all i'd be
saying yeah me my dad
i'd have a shirt my white shirt would be
like my dad's thomas yeah
we'll read the hey i'm tom hanks's son
yeah i would tell you if i was in high
school like prom homecoming
you want to come to my house yeah you
know before we tape before we go to the
dance let's go to my house meet my dad
yeah
i was like yeah good for him yeah i
think i love when he does that jamaican
voice
it's [ __ ] good it is good
is it for a jamaican voice okay i mean
yeah it's pretty
the look away that was little much yeah
the whole thing's a little awkward which
is why i enjoy it yeah that's why i
enjoy it
yeah well you wait for him to break
character he never breaks it never
no all right next one yeah all right
derek lewis is a
ufc heavyweight fighter and he posts all
these like viral videos and this one in
particular
we got tagged and i love this one
because you know brendan's kid
i guess spider-man spider-man this
spider-man came coked up
dropping conspiracy theories on the kids
out of shape
it was fantastic really yeah we got off
craigslist so i checked my car
ordered him he came to the jump place
[Music]
you haven't seen this i haven't watched
[Music]
this
oh it's so bad
the kid's back goes oh no oh my god
[Applause]
first of all what's that dance move like
what is he
is that what's he getting into there i i
don't even understand yeah
what kind of urban spider-man
yeah yeah and then
yeah here we go yeah by the way
it looked like midway he was like i'm
not making that lady back there with her
hands under her head
she knew it was bad before he landed
yeah
by the way like this map move there
what's happening look at the girls in
the back
okay all right and right here he's like
here all right we're gonna get it
oh [ __ ] yeah oh you always thinking
don't [ __ ] this up man come on this up
sounds terrible oh my god it's so great
i
i entertained at children's parties i i
um
so i when i was a lot younger and i had
a moped
um and my moped the muffler was broken
so it's
embarrassingly sounded like a harley oh
wow so when i would come down the street
i
got a guy people would expect to see a
harley and they'd see me on a
moped well this one time and the guy who
ran the company he was like i don't like
people showing up out of costume you're
gonna show up in costume
i don't want you pulling up and getting
changed at the house so i had to show
ride in costume on my moped to wherever
i was going
so this one day i'm riding in my peter
pan outfit
on my moped that goes right and i'm at
the light and i have like i got
yeah and this cop pulls up next to me
and he rolls down his window
and he goes hey i was gonna give you a
ticket for no helmet but
looks like your life is going bad enough
as it is and the light turned green and
he just drove away
and i was like yeah you're right all
right
you're right yeah you'd be careful
booking those characters
come on man you don't know who's coming
over no my kid was bummed out
methi spiderman methi of conspiracy
flat earth spiderman you had a gun i was
like
you know that suit don't fit you we know
this
you know it doesn't do it man you gotta
realize like you gotta be like this
i got a feeling who's ever taken this
job this is it this
wasn't the plan no after high school and
stuff well i'm thinking hollywood a lot
of guys trying to make it
you know like maybe dude comes in like
legit toby maguire i don't know what to
do
we we hired uh cinderella and snow white
for my daughter one year yeah and when
uh snow white showed up i told my wife
she [ __ ] all the dwarfs last night no
that [ __ ] was like craig blazer's wig
over here
she's out there trying to color with the
girls like she does not want to be here
right now i was like this
checks out it was so
bad and the kids really the kids are
like they were eating up
please don't say that oh my god what
else we got should we cut it now or just
give
us one more one more all right this is a
grizzly bear
that chased some hikers at least false
charge them
and i'll show you yellowstone glacier
montana glacier national park
jacob was just here man was he so
there's a grizzly
jesus christ he was trying to scare him
off or what well they were coming down
this trail
and then they saw the grizzly because
people were yelling like people are
filming were yelling at the grizzly
and they they're doing what you're not
supposed to do oh no i'm just running
away you know
but i heard again who knows you're
supposed to run
uphill they don't do well uphill
downhill you're [ __ ]
flat uphill they can't well even here
they said that they weren't supposed to
be running because you know it's it's
instinctual for the grizzly to chase if
you run and those are false charges
you're good
maybe that maybe they knew that but to
that point it's like that
uh boy scout leader who was like yeah
you're gonna scare the bear away and the
bear went cool i'm gonna eat you ass
first in front of all the boys
uh for me i just don't know if
if which part of my mental will because
if i see a bear running at me
i don't think what's gonna stand there
yeah that's not good
i don't yeah i don't think that's my
instinct the bear's not generating it's
a chase
aren't that's interesting is they're run
away run away like it's not a good combo
yeah together
and i don't think i could be like you
know what they say stand your ground
never i don't think i would have that in
me
i take my chance of running getting some
sort of a head start and then like
hiding behind a tree because i feel like
if it's just me i could do this behind
the tree with the bear oh you could just
run
survive like oh [ __ ] oh by the way leo
movie you can make it
you can do it i'm not gonna lie to you
that has been
for about as long as i can remember my
here's my strategy if i'm being chased
by a boar or a bear
just to run around a tree me too dude
because the boar can't run you know what
i mean
it can't run around the tree the place
for my animals
is we was at some offset zoo and my son
was like
five and there was like a panther
in this cage and my sons asked me could
the panther hurt me and i go
no you know he's in a cave my stance i
go don't tell him that
don't tell him that i mean he's not
gonna i go you're just gonna run across
a [ __ ] panther one day yeah he's like
we live in whispery meadows it's a gated
community
there's no panthers in our neighborhood
we're not worried about it
yeah i don't tell him that dude what are
you doing
like hey i don't know yeah by the way i
don't think the around the tree would
work with the bear
i think i did i think so like i'm
talking about a big thick like red one
i don't think redwood you just like yeah
i like that style
i like it i like it but rather than
sitting there watching sprinting at you
yeah i'm gonna do something i think
no they're fast i'm not
yeah they're moving so i don't think i
can outrun me either but maybe
i'm gonna take my chance you wanna talk
about fast you know the fastest
a high school dude is white right now
well he is his freshman year at georgia
he's the fan in high school he's the
fastest in the 100 the 200 the 400 and
the long jump oh we going it's matthew
bowling
is that right white boy you talking
about freshman in high school or college
uh college he just graduated in high
school last year he's a [ __ ] beast
played that would play that four by 400
where he chases the guy down he's down
like 300 yards
that one epic four don't want her come
back watch this [ __ ]
what what is he do you know what it is
he's the only white kid in the fourth
he's fourth back right
this isn't the race i'm thinking of
what is it what's the one that's called
epic well this is the one this is the
4x4 the one to four by 1600 i mean this
is only a minute
but there's one where he's so far behind
and he
chases the guy down it's crazy
like if that olympics come that one come
back four yeah
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] nut now this is
like the nat these are the top
eight teams in the country kingwood
rollette straight giant soto klein
forest converse judson klein oak
you can fast forward about two minutes
in just to get his last leg
guys miles putting desoto up 35
o'clock for just this all-time marks for
a heist yeah this is like
leg two 675
look how far back he's his team is the
green team get it out
so now we're gonna see look at him
that's him
he's got the stick and they're almost
three seconds back
come on dude down they've run a second
faster that is a huge gap to make up
listen to the announcer is eating up
ground on that back stretch
he has got so much work to do this would
be a huge task if he could do it desoto
running
21 second 200 for bowling rolling
rolling 20.
is coming here oh my god
what a freak
[Applause]
entertaining track and field
commentators of all time a 45
second 400 that's a that's in a relay
but he's the fastest in the 100
the long jump and the 200. wow
and you i said i said when the olympics
come around again
it'll be right in his he'll be right in
that age yeah early mid-20s
when you're in your pink i go i go the
black people come like this he ain't all
white yeah
he's going to be our tiger woods there's
going to be
so many white guys going out for tracks
any any way guys okay bowling okay yeah
damn i never heard him what about that's
crazy i
ran across his video one time randomly
and i've been like a fan ever since oh
i'm a fan now i'm like dude
i'm a fan of that you got to get rolling
yeah gary we love you man the podcast
they can listen uh itunes
yeah get some but always new episodes
are every thursday at 10 a.m west coast
you got some big guests too man kevin
hart tiffany haddish
you know never heard of them not yeah
yeah i just went i went small
yeah good idea in the beginning yeah
that's the stress factor of
having a podcast on your own because i
started calling everybody i knew
and i was like [ __ ] is it gonna tell
it's gonna tell me what people think of
me
yep if i don't get callbacks and they
said no yeah i like this
i was like i didn't even bother kevin i
shouted my road manager he said
yo i just talked to uh one of kevin's
boys he goes kevin stop being a [ __ ]
and call me i'll do it
i called him he's like yeah do it that's
awesome man yep
well we love you man thanks for doing
this thanks for having me guys thanks
brother buddy always good thank you very
much
tickets uh october go to
comedianjoshwolf.com and uh
always check out that dude hi live had
seven hundred and seventy thousand views
on monday night
man yeah just me smoking weed in my
backyard we're gonna be on monday night
next monday ron funtious is my guest
i love ron it's a good time i love ron
uh you're adding like
97 shows to your i think we just added
four more
yeah you've been here yeah yeah all
right man we love you guys thanks guys
take care guys